PROFESSOR: The greatest
common divisor of two numbers
is easy to compute.
And that's a factor will play
a crucial role in the number
theory we're going to develop,
and the properties of some
of the modern codes that
are based on number theory.
The efficient way to compute
the GCD of two numbers
is based on a
classical algorithm
known as Euclidean
algorithm, which
is several thousand years old.
And let's describe
how it works now.
So the Euclidean algorithm is
based on the following lemma,
which we'll call
the remainder lemma,
and it says that if a
and b are two integers,
then the greatest common
divisor of a and b
is the same as the greatest
common divisor of b,
and the remainder of a divided
by b-- providing, of course,
b is not 0, because otherwise
you can't divide by b.
OK how do you make
sense out of this?
Why is this true?
Well, it's actually
a very easy proof.
Remember that by the
so-called division algorithm--
or it's really a theorem--
if you divide a by b
and we're doing integer
division, what that means is
you find a quotient of a
divided by b in the quotient,
and a remainder.
And the quotient
has the property
that q times b plus the
remainder is equal to a.
The remainder is always
going to be smaller than a.
It will be the range from 0
up to, but not including, a.
OK, if you look at this
simple expression, what
becomes apparent is that if
you've got a divisor of two
out of three of
these terms, then
it's going to divide
the third term.
So for example, if you
have a divisor of b and r,
then the sum of those
two things is also
going to have the same
divisor, which means
that a will have that divisor.
If something divides both
a and b, then it divides r.
And if it divides b
and r, it divides a.
And that means that
a and b and b and r
have exactly the same divisors.
They not only have the same
greatest common divisor,
all their divisors are the same.
So obviously, the
greatest one is the same.
And that proves this
key remainder lemma.
Well, the remainder lemma now
gives us a very lovely way
to compute the GCD.
And here's an example.
Suppose I want to compute
the GCD of 899 and 493.
A is 899, b is 493.
Well, so I want this
GCD, 899 of 493.
Well, according to the remainder
lemma, if I divide 899 by 493,
I get a quotient of 1,
and a remainder of 406.
So that means that
899 and 493 have
the same GCD as 493 and 406.
That is the original number
b, and the new remainder 406.
But now, I can
divide 493 by 406.
I get a quotient of zero
and a remainder of 87.
So 406 and 87 have the same GCD.
Dividing 406 by 87, I get that
87 and 58 have the same GCD.
Dividing 87 by 58, I get that
58 and 29 have the same GCD.
And now I win, because look,
when I divide 58 by 29,
I get a remainder of 0.
And the GCD of anything
and 0 is that thing.
So the GCD of 29 and 0 is 0.
I guess the only exception
is the GCD of 0 and 0,
which is not defined.
But if it's not 0, then
the GCD of x and 0 is x.
And there it is.
So I've just found that the
GCD of 899 and 493 is 29.
And this is a quite
fast algorithm,
because I keep dividing
the numbers that I
have by each other,
and it gets small fast.
We'll be more precise
about that in a minute.
OK, it's a good exercise
in state machine thinking
and practice in
program verification
to reformulate the
Euclidean algorithm,
or formulate it explicitly
as a state machine.
It's a very simple
kind of state machine.
The states of this Euclidean
algorithm state machine
will be pairs of
non-negative integers.
So the states are n cross
n, the Cartesian product
of the non-negative
integers, with itself.
The start state is going
to be the pair a, b,
whose GCD I want to compute.
And the transitions are
simply repeatedly applying
the remainder lemma.
Namely, if I'm in
state x, y, where
you think of x as and y as the
GCD that I'm trying to compute,
I simply convert x and y
to y, and the remainder
of x divided by y.
And I keep doing that
as long as y is not 0.
OK, very simple state
machine-- really,
just one transition rule.
Well, according to
the lemma, since I'm
replacing the GCD of x
and y by the GCD of y
and the remainder
of x divided by y,
the GCD is actually
staying constant.
This transition
preserves the GCD
that's left in the pair
of registers, x and y.
So what we can say is that
since the GCD of x and y
doesn't change from
one step to another,
we can say that the GCD
of x and y at any point
is equal to its original value,
which is the GCD of a and b.
So in other words,
this equation,
GCD of x and y in
the current state
is equal to GCD of a and
b, the GCD of a and b
that we started with,
is a preserved invariant
of the state.
So p of a state xy, the
property that GCD of x and y
is the original GCD is
a preserved invariant
of the state machine.
Moreover, p of start
is trivially true,
because at the start,
x and y are a equals b.
So p of x and y is just
saying the GCD of a and b
is equal to GCD of a and b.
Cool.
So I've got that this
property is true at the start,
and it's preserved
by the transitions.
So the invariance
principle tells me
that if the program
stops, I'm going
to have the GCD of x
and y when it terminates
is equal to the actual
GCD that I want.
And that enables us to
prove partial correctness.
The claim is that if
this program terminates--
we haven't determined that it
does yet-- but at termination,
if any, I claim that x is left
in-- that the GCD of a and b
is left in register x.
The value of x at
the end is going
to be the GCD of and and b.
Well, why is that?
Well, look-- at termination,
what we know is that y is 0.
That's the only way that
this procedure stops,
because otherwise, the
transition rule is applicable.
So that means that
when y equals 0
at termination, what we
have is that since y is 0,
GCD of x and y is equal
to the GCD of x and 0.
And that's equal to x, assuming,
again, that x is positive,
or not 0.z
So x is the GCD of x and y.
And by the invariant,
the GCD of x and y
is equal to the GCD of a and b.
So I've prove this little fact.
This procedure correctly
computes the GCD of a and b,
leaving the answer in
register x, if it terminates.
Well, of course it terminates,
and it terminates fast.
So let's see why.
Notice that at each transition,
we're going to replace x by y,
and y by the remainder
of x divided by y.
Let's just assume
for simplicity that
of the [? pairings, ?] y
that x is the bigger one.
So there's two cases of why
these numbers are getting small
fast.
The first case is suppose
that y is less than x over 2,
or less than or
equal to x over 2.
Well, since at this step,
you're going to replace x by y,
it means that you're replacing
x by something that's
less than half x.
So x gets halved at this step.
What about if y is big?
Well, if y is bigger
than x over 2,
then the remainder of x divided
by y is simply x minus y.
And it's going to be
less than x over 2.
But that's going to be the
value of y after the next step.
So y is going to
be halved either
at this step or the next
step when it's replaced
by the remainder of x and y.
And the net result is that
y it gets cut in half,
or even smaller, at
every other step, which
means that this procedure can't
continue for more than twice
the log to the base 2 of the
original value of y, which
is b number of steps,
because that's how many
halves you can do before
you start hitting 0.
So we've just shown that
this procedure holds
in logarithmic number
of steps, which
is the same as saying that
it's about the length of b
in binary, and even fewer
steps than the length of b
in decimal.
The GCD algorithm is
really very efficient.